[MUSIC PLAYING]
HANSMAN: The invention of the
metric system in 1790 improved
matters somewhat by
basing units of measure
on more widely agreed
upon standards,
like the circumference
of the Earth.
Back at the turn
of this century,
Lord Kelvin, namesake of the
international temperature
standard, said it best.
One has but a poor understanding
of that which one cannot
measure.
Today we try to have rational,
simple, and consistent
measurement systems based on
sound scientific principles.
The goal of this video
series is to introduce you
to the principles
of measurement.
But we'll also show you some
of the standard techniques
and equipment.
The series is designed
as a basic introduction
to measurement.
It should help you
whether you are attempting
to learn about measurement
as training for new job,
or you are trying to solve a
particular measurement problem.
The series may not give
you all the answers.
But after watching,
I hope that you
will at least be able to
ask the right questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm sitting up in the
summit of Mount Washington.
And the actual summit is located
underneath this reference data
marker placed here by
the US Geological Survey.
We're going to talk about
techniques to measure distance,
velocity, and acceleration
using techniques as simple
as something like
this ruler, and as
sophisticated as this global
positioning system unit.
The fundamental standards
for the measurement
of distance, velocity,
and acceleration
are length and time.
I've come here to the museum
at the National Institute
of Standards and
Technology to show
you a few examples of current
and historical standards
of length and time.
The museum has a mission to
preserve the historic evolution
of physical measurement.
Now, the current standard
of time is the second.
And it's defined in terms of the
atomic transitions of caesium
atoms.
Caesium atoms are part
of an atomic clock.
And this is one of the
original cesium ovens.
Cesium was heated,
and a cesium beam
would be emitted from
the front of this oven
into the atomic clock.
Now, it's not practical to
have atomic clocks for day
to day time measurement.
And today we have very
good working standards
in terms of quartz
crystal oscillators,
which are seen in things
as common as my wristwatch.
Now, the international
standard for length measurement
is the meter.
And the meter was established
as an international standard
at the International Conference
of Weights and Measures
in 1889.
Because the US was a
member of that conference,
it received one of the prototype
meters, which I have here.
This prototype was one of 31
that was built at that time.
And the one that was closest
to the existing meter
was preserved in Paris as
the international standard.
And each of the countries
that participated
received at least one
of these meter bars.
The US received number 27.
This meter bar is built
out of platinum and iridium
and is accurate to
within 1.6 microns
at zero degrees centigrade.
It's 1.6 microns
short of a true meter.
Now, this was the US
standard from 1893 to 1960.
And the current standard for
the measurement of length,
or definition of
a meter is defined
in terms of the speed of light.
Some historical length
standards are based on people.
For example, this is a
replica of an Egyptian royal
qubit, which was
used about 1500 B.C.
And it was based on the
length of the forearm
of the pharaoh Amenhotep.
At MIT we also have
a unit of length,
which was based on a person.
And we've arranged to talk
to Oliver Smoot about how
this happened.
I had the privilege to
meet with Oliver Smoot, who
is a living length standard.
And Ollie, this
honor is normally
reserved for kings and pharaohs.
How did it happen to you?
SMOOT: Well I don't
know about them.
But I got it because I'm short.
HANSMAN: You're short.
SMOOT: Well, I don't know.
5'7" I guess is below
average these days.
HANSMAN: How did that get you
to become a length standard?
SMOOT: When I was
a freshman at MIT
we lived in a fraternity house
on the Boston side, Lambda Chi
Alpha.
And to get to class you had
to go across the Mass Avenue
Bridge, which is a long bridge.
You know exactly, I'm sure.
And our pledge master said,
he was late too often.
So he wanted us within a
week to measure the bridge.
And he made all
14 of the freshmen
stand up, and looked
at us, and said, Smoot,
you're the shortest.
So we'll do it in Smoots.
HANSMAN: Okay, and
how many Smoots was it
across the bridge?
SMOOT: 364.4 and an ear.
HANSMAN: How did you
get the 0.4 and an ear?
SMOOT: Well, actually there--
when we got to the
last expansion joint,
there's an actual end
to the bridge there.
It came up to about my knees.
So we did 0.4.
And decided that
since we knew there
were errors in the measure,
that we'd be honest engineers
and put a Greek E, which
means error measurement.
And then we decided
that most people
wouldn't know what that meant.
So we wrote an ear.
Because maybe that's about
the right amount of error.
HANSMAN: There's a little bridge
here at the plaza at NIST.
I wonder if I could
talk you into making
a little measurement of
this bridge in Smoots.
SMOOT: Well, if it weren't for
MIT being involved in this,
I don't think so.
But sure.
HANSMAN: All right.
This will be a
credible measurement.
Now, let's start at the edge
of the water, over here.
SMOOT: Okay.
HANSMAN: Okay.
Okay, Ollie.
I'm going to put a
reference mark here
at the start of the
bridge over the water.
So.
SMOOT: All right.
Let's see what we get.
HANSMAN: Okay, yeah.
Let's see what you did.
All right?
Okay.
Now.
SMOOT: Aim for the top.
HANSMAN: All right.
Your head's the top.
SMOOT: Okay.
HANSMAN: Okay.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Okay, Ollie.
We've now officially measured
the bridge here at the National
Institute of Standards
and Technology.
And it looks like you're about
1/10 of a Smoot short of 4.
SMOOT: Yeah.
HANSMAN: So we're 3.9 Smoots.
SMOOT: Plus or minus an ear.
HANSMAN: All right.
Plus or minus an ear.
All right.
Now, you said
you're about 5' 7".
And so one Smoot is
about 5 feet 7 inches.
You think you're still 5' 7"?
Is the Smoot a stable
reference standard?
SMOOT: Maybe, because
my hair is thinner.
I don't know.
Sometime, I guess
I'll get shorter.
But so far, it seems
to be about the same.
HANSMAN: I've come to one
of the experimental research
facilities here at
MIT's Lincoln Laboratory
to talk about distance,
velocity, and acceleration
measurement.
The antenna you see above me is
an air traffic control radar,
which is used to
measure the position
and velocity of aircraft.
This is the radar
controller station
at the Lincoln Laboratory
experimental radar facility.
Perhaps the simplest method
for measuring distance
is by the use of
calibrated length scales,
such as this tape measure
or this ruler here.
Now, the maximum
resolution you can
get with a calibrated
scale, such as this ruler,
depends on the minimum
graduation of the scale.
You can see this ruler is
calibrated both in centimeters
and in inches.
And the finest graduation
of the centimeter scale
is 1 millimeter.
So this system is really
only usable for accuracies
down to, say, a fraction
of a millimeter.
Now, rulers and
tape measures are
good for measuring
linear distances
where you can actually put
the edge you want to measure
right up against the scale.
So you can get a fairly accurate
measurement of the dimensions.
Now, you get into
trouble if you try
to measure something
like the diameter
of this pipe with a ruler.
The problem is that, because you
can't put the edge of the pipe
right up against the
ruler, you run into what
we call parallax error.
If you move your
head, what happens
is that the apparent edge of
the pipe will move around.
So you can't get a very
accurate measurement.
Now, we can actually use
something like this caliper,
here, to measure the
dimension of the pipe.
What I can do--
let me just do it
from the top, here--
is squeeze down on the
pipe with this caliper.
And you can see this is an
electronic caliper, which
measures the diameter at
about 15.98 millimeters.
I can also flip
the calipers over
and use these feelers to
measure the inside diameter
of the pipe.
And the caliper also
has a probe here
that can be used
for measuring down
inside the pipe, the
depth of the pipe.
Now, I could also use something
that we call a micrometer.
This is very commonly used
in mechanical measurements,
machining, things like that.
And essentially, what it
is, is a calibrated screw.
What I do is I
twist the screw down
until it squeezes on the pipe.
And when the screw hits the
pipe, it stops rotating.
Now, because I have a fair
amount of mechanical advantage
twisting the screw,
I need to be careful
that I actually don't
deform the pipe-- squeeze it
so much that I deform it.
And the way I do that is by
using this little knob here,
which is a spring-loaded knob.
And essentially, what I do
is I rotate the screw using
the spring-loaded knob.
And it always applies the
same amount of torque.
So I essentially get the
same tension on the screw
every time.
And it makes the
measurement repeatable.
Now, it's common for machinists
to use something called a dial
gauge here.
And essentially, what
the dial gauge does
is I have this plunger that
pushes up against the object.
And it will rotate the dial.
So there's a very fine
mechanism inside the gauge that
will make a measurement
of the position
and show it on
this needle, here.
And you can see that just my
jiggling around here as I talk
is causing the system to jump.
Now, because the
mechanism is very fine,
what happens is that
sometimes the needle zero
position will shift.
And you can see that I can
just rotate the dial, here,
to re-zero the instrument.
Now, for some applications,
you want an electrical output
rather than a mechanical
output of position.
And there are different
ways you can do this.
One common technique is
by using a potentiometer.
And they're are, in
fact, many potentiometers
in this oscilloscope.
All the knobs,
here, are connected
to potentiometers, which are
essentially just resistors.
And as I rotate the position
of the knob, what I'm doing
is changing the value
of the resistance.
So you can see, as I change
the position of the knob
here, what I'm doing is changing
the resistance, which then
shows up as a change
in voltage on the face
of the oscilloscope, here.
So if I change it
a lot, you ought
to be able to see that
show up on the scope.
Now, this is a measurement
of rotary position.
But I also am interested,
sometimes, in linear position.
I can also use a
potentiometer there.
But we can use a technique
called a Linear Variable
Displacement
Transducer, or LVDT.
Now, what an LVDT
is, is essentially
an inductor, which is in
this metal core, here.
And inside the inductor
is a magnetic material--
I think, this
case, it's nickel--
which goes down
inside the inductor.
When it does, it
changes the inductance,
which is measured by a circuit.
The circuit is powered by
the small power supply here
and is actually
inside the metal tube.
The output of the circuit
is a voltage, which I'm now
showing on the oscilloscope.
And you can see that if I change
the position of the plunger,
I get an electrical
output of voltage.
Okay.
If I pull the core
too far out, you
can see that the
instrument saturates.
Okay.
So its usable range is
just a few inches, here,
in the middle of the motion.
So far, the smallest distances
we've talked about measuring
are a thousandth of an inch
or a fraction of a millimeter.
Sometimes, you need to make
measurements more accurately.
And to do this, you can't really
use mechanical techniques.
However, you can use
optical techniques.
For example, this laser here
has a-- you can see the red dot
on my hand--
has a wavelength
of 633 nanometers,
which is about 0.6
millionths of a meter.
And by using
interference techniques,
we can make measurements
on that level of accuracy.
Now, there are many different
types of interferometers.
And what I want to do is talk
to you about a simple one,
just to give you a
feel for the concept.
This is an example of a
Michelson interferometer,
which can accurately measure the
difference between two paths.
Light comes from the laser and
is split at a beam splitter
into a measurement path
and a reference path.
The light goes out and is
reflected off of a mirror
and sent back to the beam
splitter along both paths.
The light is then
recombined and picked up
in a detector, which measures
intensity of the combined
light.
Now, if the paths are
identical, the waves
from the reference path
and the measurement path
will be in phase and
will add together.
However, if the paths are
different by a quarter
of a wavelength,
what will happen
is the waves will
actually cancel--
will come back 180
degrees out of phase
and cancel-- so there'll be
no intensity at the detector.
So as the measurement
path increases
in length, what will happen
is the intensity measured
at the detector will go
through minimums and maximums.
We call these fringes.
And by counting the
number of fringes,
you can actually measure
the change in length
along the measurement path.
And again, as you
can see, this can
be accurate to a fraction
of a wavelength, which
is very small distance.
Many techniques for
measuring distance
use the principle
of time of flight
of some wave to make the
distance measurement.
For example, this ultrasonic
distance measuring unit, here,
is used for measuring
the dimensions of rooms.
So when I push this
button, what happens
is an ultrasonic wave is
emitted from this transducer,
is sent out, and
bounced off the wall.
The reflected wave is picked
up by this second transducer,
over here.
If I measure the
round trip time,
I can figure out the
distance to the wall.
The distance is essentially
the round trip time,
times the speed of sound,
divided by 2 because it
was the out and return time.
Now, that measurement
will be fairly accurate
if you know the speed
of sound in air.
Now, the speed of sound is
about 300 meters per second.
However, it depends
on the temperature.
So this measurement
will only be accurate
if you are at the temperature
that the unit is calibrated for
or if you correct for changes
in the speed of sound.
Now, we actually looked at
another ultrasonic measuring
unit when we were down at
the Omega Engineering labs.
And let's go look at that now.
This is an ultrasonic distance
and level measurement system.
And what happens
here is that there
is an ultrasonic transducer
in the top of the unit, which
transmits an acoustic
wave, which reflects off
of the object we're
trying to measure
and comes back
down into the unit.
The transducer actually
looks something like this.
As I move the plexiglass
plate, here, you
can see that the
distance is shorter.
So it takes less time for the
wave to go up to the plexiglass
and back.
Now, the beauty
of this method is
that you don't
need direct contact
between the sensor
and the object
you're trying to measure.
Acoustic time-of-flight
techniques
can also be used for making
distance measurements
in fluids, such as water.
Now, the speed of sound
in seawater, for example,
is much faster than air.
It's about 1,500
meters per second.
And these techniques
are commonly
used in sonars and depth
finders on ships and submarines.
One of the important
distance measurements
they make on this vessel is the
amount of water under the keel.
Now, they actually have
several sensors on board
the vessel that use
sonars or depth finders
to figure out the distance.
They all work on basically
the same principle.
Over here, there's a depth
finder that says 22 feet.
Now, the way they work
is an acoustic wave
is sent from the bottom of the
ship down through the water.
It bounces off of the
bottom of the harbor
and is received by a transducer
in the bottom of the ship.
By knowing the speed of sound
in the water and the round trip
time, we can figure out
the depth under the keel.
This radar unit uses
time-of-flight techniques
with radio waves.
This unit has about a
10-centimeter wavelength.
And for wavelengths between
1 and 30 centimeters,
we normally call
these microwaves.
Now, basically,
the way this works
is there's an
antenna up in a tower
above this building, which
transmits radio waves out.
And the radio waves are
reflected by airplanes
flying around the Boston area.
Because the radio waves
aren't attenuated in air
as strongly as acoustic
waves, this technique
is good for much
larger distances.
Also the radio waves
travel much faster.
So the radar, here, is
currently set for range
of about 60 nautical miles.
And it's common to use radars
at even longer distances.
In fact, we measure the distance
between the Earth and planets
using radar techniques.
Now, so far, we've
only been talking
about measuring distance.
But you can see
in the radar plot
that the radar also measures
the direction to the target.
We do this by rotating
the radar antenna.
And let's go up to the tower
and take a look at the antenna.
I'm up here on the antenna
platform of this airport
surveillance radar.
And the antenna
above me is spinning
at 4.8 seconds per revolution.
Now, if I shut off the
antenna, it'll stop.
We can take a look at how
the antenna actually works.
Now, if you look
closely, you can
see that there are
two transmitting
and receive horns at the focus
of the parabolic antenna.
Microwaves are emitted
from the transmitting horn.
They go out and are
reflected off the parabola
and focused into a
relatively narrow beam,
at a beam width of
about 1.4 degrees.
Now, the antenna also
works the other way, too.
So microwaves reflected
off of targets
will come back and be focused
into the receive horn.
Now, you'll notice that the
antenna is wider horizontally
than it is vertically.
That's because, for
this type of radar,
we actually want a
narrow beam horizontally.
But we actually want a defocused
or broad beam vertically,
so that we get what
we call a fan beam.
And that allows us to scan
all altitudes at one rotation.
Some types of radars or
some satellite receivers
actually have a circular
parabolic antenna.
And that gives a very tight
beam in both horizontally
and vertically-- what
we call a pencil beam.
Let's now take a look at a
very basic radar display.
What I have here is what
we call Plan Position
Indication display, or PPI.
In the PPI, the
antenna location is
at the center of the display.
And you can see the
rotation of the antenna
as it rotates in what we
call the azimuthal direction.
Each of the aircraft targets
that the radar sees shows
up as a what we call blip.
And if you look
carefully at the blip,
you can see some features that
indicate the uncertainties
in the measurement.
If you'll notice,
the targets show up
wide in the azimuthal direction
but very narrow in the range
direction.
And what that tells you is
that the range measurement
of the radar is much more
precise than the angle
measurement or
azimuthal measurement.
So the targets show up
as these sort of spread
out targets in the
azimuthal direction.
Now, this simple radar screen
just shows the primary returns
from the targets.
And if we look over here,
there's a more modern--
in fact, this is a
research display--
showing some of the
other information
the air traffic controllers get.
Now, let me orient you
to the display, here.
Again, the radar
location, here, is
at the center of the display.
And you can see range rings.
Here's one 10 nautical
miles out from the radar.
Hanscom Airport is located
here, right next to the radar.
And you can see the
runways at Hanscom.
If you look down
to the right, you
can see Boston Logan Airport,
again, the runways showing
as white lines.
And there are some
light gray lines,
which show you
the coast and some
of the main roads around Boston.
Now, if we look at one
of the aircraft targets,
you can see that there's
much more information here
than just the blip we
saw on the other radar.
First off, the best estimate
of the location of the target
is shown.
And there's some
secondary information
you can see, over here.
Now, most of the aircraft
flying around Boston
actually have equipment on board
to enhance their radar returns.
And this equipment's
called a transponder.
And what it does is, when
it receives the radar
pulse on board the
aircraft, there
is a second transmitter
on the aircraft that
sends a return
pulse, which is much
stronger than the
basic reflection
that you would have from what
we call a primary target.
Now, along with that
pulse, the aircraft
sends down some information.
You can see this target here.
The top line is the
identification number
of the target.
So it's sending
down a code of 5153.
And below that
identification number
are three digits, which indicate
the altitude of the target.
So this aircraft is at
2,000 feet above sea level.
This radar also
infers the velocity
of the aircraft
from radar returns.
So this little trail,
here, is essentially
the last 10 hits that the
radar has had on the target.
So again, that's
the last 48 seconds
of data from the target.
And by the way, I
should have mentioned,
I've frozen the display
here so we could look at it.
So based on those last
10 hits, the radar
has calculated
that the target is
moving at about 110
knots of ground speed.
And it's moving to the west.
So the air traffic controller
can figure out not only
the location of the targets,
but where they're moving
and if there's any
problems with collisions.
Now, radars are used
for other applications.
For example, we can use
radars to reflect off
of rain and precipitation.
And if you look
over here, you can
see that I have a
computer output of a radar
down in Florida, which
happens, this morning,
to be looking at a hurricane
which is just hitting
the panhandle of Florida.
We can also use radars on
other vehicles, such as ships.
And let's now go down
to the NOAA research
vessel, Albatross, to look
at the radars on board
that vessel.
This is the radar display on
the bridge of the NOAA research
vessel, Albatross IV.
This is a display
of a primary radar,
with the antennas mounted
on top of the bridge, here.
As the radar rotates,
it sends out signals,
which are bounced off of either
ship targets or land targets.
And it can give us a picture.
Now, the radar is actually used
for two purposes on the ship.
One is to navigate,
and the other
is to avoid colliding
with other ships or boats.
We're now moored in Woods Hole,
Massachusetts, heading south.
And I've set the display up here
at about a six nautical mile
range.
And you can see the coast
of Martha's Vineyard
across Vineyard Sound, here.
You can also see, if you
look closely-- in fact,
let me increase the range,
adjust the display a little
bit--
you can see the black area is
the channel through Woods Hole.
Now, as I said before, we also
use the radar to avoid targets.
And the dots that
you see in the black
are actually individual
ships or boats.
If I increase the range
a little bit more,
you can see a couple
things in the display.
First, these straight
lines in front of us
are actually the jetties
out in front of the ship.
And you can see a few targets.
I have one on the right, here.
Let me mark it.
There's a little cursor.
And if I mark this
target, you can
see that there's a boat 0.17
nautical miles to my right.
It's on the 078 degree bearing.
If we look out there, we can
see that the boat that I marked
was actually the
12-meter yacht, Shamrock,
which is moored in the harbor
next to us, here, at the dock.
We've talked about techniques
for measuring distance using
acoustic waves and radio waves.
But you can also use
time-of-flight techniques
with light or
infrared radiation.
And in fact, much
of the equipment
that's used for land surveying
uses time-of-flight techniques
of infrared radiation.
Now, I made
arrangements with one
of the surveyors who
works with MIT to show you
this equipment by measuring
one of the buildings at MIT.
Distance measurement is an
important part of surveying.
And Ken Strom, who's
a professional land
surveyor for Cullen
Engineering, has
agreed to help us do a
survey problem here at MIT.
What I'd like to do-- what
I thought would be fun--
is to try to measure the exact
height of the Great Dome,
here, behind me.
So, Ken, how do we have
to-- what do we have to do,
to do this?
STROM: Well, what we did was we
established a point over here,
which has a known position.
And we also established
an elevation on that point
by turning on it, using
differential leveling
techniques from a
deep benchmark, which
was established in 1927,
located near the corner
of this building
right behind us, here.
HANSMAN: Okay.
So we know the
height of this point.
And we can then measure the
difference between this point
and the top of the Dome.
STROM: Yes.
Utilizing our total
station instrument,
we can establish a difference in
elevation between the sidewalk,
here, and the top of the dome.
HANSMAN: Surveying
requires a measurement
of both the distance
and direction
from the known point,
or reference mark,
to the point you're
trying to measure.
Traditionally, we would use
something like this steel tape
to measure the distance
and an instrument
called a theodolite to measure
the direction of the distance.
Nowadays, it's very common
to use something called
a total station
instrument, which
combines an
electronic measurement
of the distance with an
of the angles.
Now, the way this
particular unit works is it
has an infrared signal, which
is emitted from these optics.
The wavelength of the infrared
signal is about 0.9 microns.
And that wavelength is chosen
for eye safety reasons.
What happens is the infrared
signal comes out from the unit
and is reflected
back by a reflector
that we set at the
measurement point.
This particular reflector,
here, is a prism.
And so we measure the
distance from the instrument
to the reflector by
measuring the time
it takes the infrared signal
to go out to the reflector
and go back.
And that round trip time is,
essentially, the distance
divided by the speed of light.
Now, the speed of light
in air is the speed
of light in vacuum, about 3
times 10 to the eighth meters
per second, divided by the index
of refraction of in the air.
And so we have to correct
for both the temperature
and pressure, which influence
the index of refraction.
Now, the reason
why we use a prism
is that we want to make sure
that we have a good signal
going back to the instrument.
If I use something just like a
mirror, if it was misaligned,
I might run into a problem.
So this prism is what
we call a corner cube.
If we send the light
into the corner,
no matter which
direction it comes from,
it'll go straight back
out at the instrument.
It's a very common technique.
In fact, there are some corner
cubes set up on the moon
that we use to
measure the distance
between the Earth and the moon.
So, Ken, what we
need to do here is
find the height
of the instrument
before I go up in the
Dome to set up the prism.
STROM: Yes.
As we mentioned earlier,
we established an elevation
of our reference
mark with relation
to mean sea level datum.
And that was done via
differential leveling
techniques.
And we've established an
elevation of 10.02 feet
on the reference mark.
And what we will do is
measure up with a ruler
to an index mark
on the instrument.
And that will-- we're
measuring 5.36 feet
above the reference
mark, which establishes
an elevation of the instrument
of 15.38 feet above mean sea
level.
HANSMAN: Okay.
I've got the prism up here.
I actually had to
pull it up on a line.
And I set it up on
this tripod, which
is right over the
middle of the Dome.
And what I'll do is I'll
try and align it to Ken.
And, Ken, do you have a good
line of sight to the prism?
Ken, do you have a good
STROM: John, I can see
you through my crosshairs.
Over.
HANSMAN: All right.
Good.
All right.
I'll just secure it here.
And I'll be down in a minute
to make the measurement.
STROM: Okay.
HANSMAN: Okay.
I think we're stable.
It's pretty windy up here,
so we've tied down the prism.
And I'll head down now.
And we'll see what the
height of this place is.
Okay.
Ken, now that I have the prism
set up on top of the Dome,
we need to line up the
instrument on the prism?
STROM: Yes.
Yes.
The prism, now, is
in the crosshairs.
HANSMAN: Okay.
And if we press this
angle button, what we see
is that the angle of the line
of sight from the vertical,
which we call the
zenith angle, is what?
STROM: 77 degrees, 44
minutes, and 5 seconds.
HANSMAN: Okay.
And if we make the
range measurement.
STROM: Yes.
The slope measurement
is 693.215 feet.
HANSMAN: So that's the
distance between the instrument
and the prism.
STROM: Yes.
HANSMAN: And the
actual height is
that distance times the
cosine of the zenith angle--
STROM: Correct.
HANSMAN: --which
now is 147.275 feet.
Before I take down
the prism, I figured
we might as well take a look
around while we're up here,
on top of the Great Dome.
You can see the Green
Building at MIT.
And across the
Charles River, you
can see the skyline of Boston.
There's the Hancock Tower
and the Prudential Tower.
And down there, you can
actually see the Mass Ave
Bridge, or the Harvard Bridge.
Well, when we had
Ken here, I couldn't
resist asking him to come
out to the Harvard Bridge
to see if we could see how
long the bridge is in feet,
to compare that with Smoots.
Because the bridge is
curved, we actually
had to set up the station
in the middle of the bridge.
And we put prisms on both ends.
So, Ken, why don't you
go ahead and see if you
can measure the first prism.
STROM: 1,014.53 feet.
HANSMAN: Okay.
So that's the distance
from about the middle
of the bridge to the other--
to the north end.
And what we'll do
is we'll switch it.
And we'll shoot the other side.
Okay.
Then we'll go ahead and
make the measurement here.
Okay.
I got it lined up.
Let me measure.
Okay, Ken, it's 1,008.27 feet.
STROM: 1,008.27.
HANSMAN: Okay.
So the total length
of the bridge is--
STROM: We had 1,014.53
heading towards Cambridge.
So the total would
be 2,022.8 feet.
HANSMAN: Okay.
So and that's equal to 3--
STROM: 364.4 Smoots.
HANSMAN: And an ear.
STROM: Yes.
One ear.
HANSMAN: One very important
type of distance measurement
is navigation or locating
your position in space.
Now, in order to
do this, you need
some sort of coordinate system.
On the surface of the
Earth, we use, essentially,
a spherical coordinate
system because the earth
is approximately a sphere.
Now the system we use is the
latitude-longitude system.
0 degrees latitude is,
essentially, the equator.
And it rotates in
angular measurement,
from the center of the Earth
up to 90 degrees at the North
Pole, and 90 degrees
south at the South Pole.
Now, longitude is defined in
terms of east-west position.
And 0 degrees longitude
is in Greenwich, England,
very close to London.
And again, longitude
goes east and west,
from that 0 position to 180
degrees at the International
Date Line in the
middle of the Pacific.
Now, our location,
here in Boston, is--
let's find Greenwich again--
is about 70 degrees west
of Greenwich, England,
and again, about 45 degrees
north from the equator.
So our latitude is
45 degrees north,
and our longitude is
about 70 degrees west.
Now, there are
many different ways
we can measure position, ranging
from celestial navigation
techniques, where we locate
our position on the Earth
with regard to stars, such as
the North Star or other stars
in the sky at night.
We can also use radio
navigation techniques,
where we measure our position
with regard to radio beacons
on the Earth.
But perhaps the most
important new technique
is something that's called
a global positioning system.
This is a small Global
Positioning System,
or GPS, receiver.
Basically, GPS is another
time-of-flight technique
using radio waves.
But the transmitters are
mounted on a constellation
of satellites, which
orbits the Earth.
Right now, there are
about 24 satellites
in the constellation.
And they're designed such
that, at any one time,
you should be able to see
somewhere between four
and eight satellites.
A computer in the receiver
knows where all the satellites
should be at any one time.
So by measuring the distance
to several satellites,
you can figure
out your location.
Now, you actually need
to measure the distance
to at least four satellites.
And that's because the
clock in the receiver
is not as accurate as
the clocks on satellites.
So by making four
measurements, we
can resolve the three
components of position--
say, north, east, and down--
and also correct any uncertainty
in the receiver clock.
Now, the accuracy of the
GPS depends on the geometry
of the satellites.
In order to get a
good measurement,
you'd really like the
satellites to be spread out.
If all the satellites
were in the same position,
you'd essentially just be
making the same measurement
four times.
So you can see in
this figure here,
if we just look
at two satellites,
if I'm a certain range
from satellite A,
I could be anywhere on this
line with some uncertainty.
Now, if I measure from satellite
B, I could be on this line.
And my position would
be in the region
covered by the intersection
of the two lines.
But I could be anywhere within
the intersection of the two
uncertainty bands.
Now, if the satellites
were close together,
you can see the
region of uncertainty
becomes much larger.
And this effect is
called the Geometric
Dilution of Precision, or GDOP.
And it's normally
monitored by the receiver.
Now, if the GDOP is
too large, or if you
can't see enough satellites,
then your receiver
should warn you that your
measurement of position
is unreliable.
Now, there are
other factors which
can influence the precision
of a GPS measurement.
And one of those is the
accuracy of the receiver.
Now, this receiver uses what's
called a civil, or C/A, code.
And most civil
receivers use that code.
The military uses another
code, called the P code.
And the civil C/A
code is intentionally
degraded by the military
for political reasons.
So that measurement
will only be accurate to
within a few hundred feet.
And we actually checked this
by taking this receiver up
on top of the Great Dome
to measure the GPS position
and compare it with
Ken's surveyed position.
This is a civil GPS unit, so
it only uses the C/A code.
You can see, here--
here's the antenna.
Here's the unit--
right now there
are six satellites available
to us and potentially in view.
And the GPS is locked up
on all six satellites.
Okay.
So what we'll do is we'll now
press the navigation page.
And we can see that
the GPS only thinks
we're 37 feet above sea level.
You'll see that drift around
a little bit as the satellites
move.
However, the latitude and
longitude are also displayed.
We're 42 degrees, 21 minutes, 58
seconds north, and 71 degrees,
5 minutes, 53 seconds
west according to the GPS.
We can also see how far we
are from a reference point.
Right now, we have
Logan Airport in here.
And Logan Airport is 3.58
nautical miles just about due
east of us, 0.80 degrees.
So in fact, if you
look at it, you'll
be able to see
the tower of Logan
Airport, off in the distance.
When I compared the GPS-measured
coordinates of the Great
Dome with the surveyed
coordinates that Ken gave me,
I found that the GPS located
the Great Dome a few hundred
feet north and west
of Ken's location.
And most of this
difference was due
to the selective
availability effect.
Now, there are
ways we can correct
for selective availability
and other errors.
And one of these is something
called differential GPS.
Now, with differential
GPS, what you do
is you have another GPS receiver
at a known surveyed location.
And what it does is essentially
calculates the current error
due to selective availability.
It then transmits
this correction up
to the operational GPS receiver
so that you can locate position
much more accurately.
Basically, you're
just compensating out
the selective
availability effect.
With differential GPS, it's
possible to get your position
to within a few feet
if you're fairly
close to the known
surveyed receiver.
Now, you can even do better.
You can get accuracies as
high as a few centimeters
or a few millimeters if you use
interferometric GPS techniques.
Now, we've talked about a lot of
distance measuring techniques.
And what I'd like
to do now is go out
and show you a simple example
of a velocity measurement
technique.
Every time you drive
a car, you actually
see a velocity measurement
on the speedometer
in front of you.
Now, my bike has an
odometer, which actually
works on the same principle.
Now, the way most
odometers work is
by counting the number of
rotations of the wheel.
In this case, on my bike here,
I have a magnetics pickup.
There's a small magnet
attached to the spoke.
And there's a
magnetic sensor, here.
Every time the magnet
goes by the sensor,
it creates a little
voltage pulse.
And that pulse is sent up this
wire to the computer unit,
here.
Now, the computer unit
has a quartz clock in it.
And the quartz
clock, essentially,
counts the number of
pulses per second.
If I know the
circumference of the wheel,
I can figure out
what the velocity is.
So for example, if
I spin the wheel,
you can see that there is an
indication of pulses, here.
And I get an
indication of velocity.
I can also integrate
the number of pulses,
and I can get a total
distance covered.
In fact, on this ride,
I've gone about 12.1 miles.
I can accumulate that over time.
So for example, the total number
of miles I've ridden this bike
is about 1,540.
Now, we can measure velocity
using other techniques.
For example, we can
measure velocity
by differentiating
position measurements.
So for example, if
we take the GPS unit
and differentiate position, we
can get a velocity measurement.
At the 25 or 30 miles an
hour I max out on my bike,
there's not much risk I'm
going to get pulled over
for speeding.
However, it's interesting
to see how police actually
measure velocity.
Let's go take a
look at that now.
We're out here on Memorial
Drive in front of MIT,
where I've enlisted the help
of Sergeant Eric Anderson,
from the Massachusetts
State Police,
to show us some of the different
velocity-measurement techniques
that are commonly used.
We're going to look at both
a Doppler radar technique
and a LIDAR technique.
This is a standard
Doppler radar unit.
And the way it works is by
using the Doppler effect.
Now, what the
Doppler effect is, is
a shift in frequency caused by
the relative motion of objects.
And you're maybe familiar
with this if you've ever heard
a train whistle come at you.
You'll hear the tone
change as it comes at you
and then goes away.
You can almost hear it in
some of these cars going by.
The tone of the cars
changes as it goes by.
Now, this same effect occurs
with electromagnetic waves.
And this unit uses a
microwave with a wavelength
of about 1 centimeter.
And that's a frequency
of about 24 gigahertz.
Now, what happens
is the wave goes out
from the gun to the
approaching vehicle
and is reflected off
the approaching vehicle.
The vehicle sees
a Doppler shift.
And the amount of
the Doppler shift
is proportional to the
velocity of the car divided
by the speed of light.
So what the unit does is
actually very carefully
compares the outgoing frequency
to the return frequency
and then measures speed.
Now, there is a little bit of a
problem with this unit, in that
it's got a fairly wide beam.
The beam width is
about 12 degrees.
So it sort of sprays
out over the whole road.
That's okay, because
what it will do
is it will lock onto the
largest signal that's returning.
That'll either be the closest
vehicle or, in some cases,
the biggest vehicle.
If you have a bus or something
like that, what will happen
is you'll get a
large radar return.
But it's a very good unit.
There are some
other units that are
used that have actually
tighter beam widths.
And that's what the
advantage of the laser unit.
Let's take a look at that now.
ANDERSON: Trooper White is now
utilizing the laser unit, which
is a relatively recent
speed-measuring technology
for the law
enforcement community.
We really like it because
it's officer-interactive.
And the width of the
beam is more specific.
So we're actually targeting
in on the specific vehicle
without question.
HANSMAN: Yeah.
The laser unit actually is--
even though it's more modern--
it's simpler in principle.
What it does is it uses a
time-of-flight technique
and makes a range
measurement to the vehicle.
What you do is it sends out
an infrared pulse, which
goes out and bounces off
the vehicle and comes back.
And by knowing the speed
of light and the time
it took the pulse to
go out and come back,
you can measure the
distance to the vehicle.
Then what you do is you measure
the distance several times
and get an estimate of the
velocity of the vehicle.
You've got to be a
little bit careful.
You can't just do
it with two pulses,
because you might first get a
hit on the front of the vehicle
and then get one on the
mirror or something like that.
So that would cause an
error in the measurement.
And what these units do is
make a lot of measurements--
about 360 a second--
to get an accurate
measurement of the velocity.
This gun operates at a
wavelength of 0.9 microns.
And the reason it does that
is for eye safety reasons.
If you were to go to
shorter, visible wavelengths,
the light actually
penetrates into the eye
and could damage the retina.
And at longer
wavelengths, the energy
is absorbed in the
outer part of the eye
and might damage the outer part.
So this is actually
the best frequency
to use for eye safety reasons.
And as you said, the
lasers have the advantage
over the radars in the fact
that they have a very tight beam
width.
This unit has a beam width
of about 2/10 of a degree.
So you can really focus
on a specific vehicle,
whereas the radar had a very
wide beam width of 12 degrees.
I would now like to
talk a little bit
about the measurement
of acceleration.
Now, in principle, we
can measure acceleration
through the force it exerts.
Since force is
equal to mass times
acceleration, if we
have a known mass,
we can, again, figure out
the acceleration from force.
And most accelerometers
work on that principle.
You can see with this
spring mass system, here,
I have 100 gram mass.
And the acceleration
due to gravity
shows me 100 grams on the scale.
If I were to increase the
acceleration-- if I were,
basically, to accelerate the
system up or let it come down,
let it drop--
I would get a variation
in the force that
was read on the scale, here.
In fact, if I were to
drop the spring scale,
the spring would return to
zero since I'm now in freefall.
In fact, you can see that this
creates a complication for us,
on the surface of the Earth, if
we want to measure acceleration
for the purposes of figuring
out what the subsequent velocity
would be.
Because on the
surface of the Earth,
even though this isn't moving,
it feels that 1g acceleration
down.
The acceleration we
feel on the Earth
is a combination of the
gravitational acceleration
and something that we call
the inertial acceleration.
And in fact, that
inertial acceleration
is what you would
integrate to get velocity.
Now, like I say,
most accelerometers
use this principle.
However, most accelerometers
aren't this crude.
I have, here, an example of a
piezoelectric accelerometer.
And again, essentially,
what it has is the same sort
of thing on the inside.
It's got a small proof
mass or test mass inside.
And it has a sensor.
In this case it's a
piezoelectric sensor.
Now that piezoelectric
sensor sends a voltage out
to this amplifier.
And then that
amplifier brings it up
to a level which can be
detected on this oscilloscope.
Now, if I move the
accelerometer up and down,
you can see that the
acceleration signal shows up
on the scope, here.
Now, one problem with
piezoelectric accelerometers
is that they really only
measure changes in acceleration.
They're what we call AC devices.
You need to use a different
type of accelerometer
if you are really interested
in measuring the static, or DC,
acceleration.
Another thing to notice is that
this particular accelerometer
is really only sensitive
in one direction.
And that's very common.
Right now, its direction of
sensitivity is up and down.
Okay.
So again, if I move
it up and down,
I get a pretty good signal.
If I move it left
and right, you can
see that I don't get
too much of a signal.
In fact, any signal you do
get is just due to the fact
that I can't move it
left and right perfectly.
Now, we talked a little bit
about integrating acceleration
to get velocity.
And in fact, there's
a navigation principle
that's based on this.
This is a model--
actually, it's an old model--
of an inertial navigation unit.
And in principle, if you
have three accelerometers,
one measuring, say, north--
the yellow things, here,
are the accelerometers--
one measuring east,
and one measuring down,
and you knew your starting
position and starting velocity,
you could integrate
the acceleration
to get velocity and integrate
the velocity to get position.
So you would be able to navigate
without ever having to make
any outside measurements.
And this is very desirable for
applications such as submarines
and some flight vehicles.
And units like this are called
inertial navigation systems.
Now, it isn't sufficient to
just measure the acceleration,
because you also have to be
able to know which direction you
were going.
So these three red devices,
here, are gyroscopes.
And what they do is they
measure any rotations
that the vehicle has undergone.
Essentially, in an older system,
such as this gimbal-based
system, what would happen
is if the platform rotated--
if the vehicle rotated--
the gimbals would
adjust and keep
the accelerometers oriented
north, east, and down.
Nowadays, it's more common
to do that computationally.
So basically, all
the sensors would
be fixed in what we call a
strapdown inertial system.
Now, one thing to think
about with inertial systems
is that any errors
in the sensors,
either the gyros or
the accelerometers,
are integrated
actually two times.
So an error in
acceleration would
be integrated once, to result
in an error in velocity.
And that velocity
error would then
be integrated and result
in an error in position.
So errors in inertial
systems tend to build.
And it's necessary to
periodically update
both the alignment and the
position of an inertial system
to cancel out those errors.
We've talked about
techniques for measuring
distance, velocity, and
acceleration, ranging
from simple
mechanical techniques
to a variety of
time-of-flight techniques.
Since distance, velocity,
and acceleration
are related quantities,
we can often
use a technique to measure
one to infer another.
However, it's
important to remember
that distance, velocity,
and acceleration
are vector quantities.
So it's important
to consider both
the magnitude and direction
when making a measurement.
[MUSIC PLAYING]